yeah like in terms of like any of my
non-hip hop like podcast listening it's
pretty much all ringer universe and Joe
Rogan yeah because I [__] love uh I
love uh the mismatch too with Verno and
Kevin oconnell my that's my NBA [__] big
Rogan guy huh yeah I like Rogan what do
you like about him I just like the fact
that like anybody who comes like it's
you like he'll have a crazy conversation
with like a comedian and then he'll have
another conversation with like some dude
who's like self-efficient setting up
like Farmland grid and then another guy
who like talked about like [__] you
know uh like like mapping out the old
world you know what I mean I mean he he
did an interview with the GU with a guy
who went and investigated the uh the the
mines in Congo uh the Cobalt mines in
Congo that was [__] crazy
that like I just feel like if you if Joe
Rogan there's enough it's just such a
vast range of conversations makes you
gives you more Tools in your
intellectual tool belt and I wouldn't
even say that it just kind of like cuz I
I don't agree with everything that's
said on the podcast you know like the
[__]
word well yeah I mean wait you do agree
with the [__] word I didn't say that
well see see look at what you did this
is the way this is wait this is why you
got to be careful cuz like you're you're
[__] you know what this is this is
TMZ level [__] going this is where
yeah what you think I learned this is
where you got to be this is where you
got to be careful this is where you got
to be careful cuz I could make that I
could that I could make that clip look a
crazy way I in my head that's what I can
make that clip crazy like no you can't
make it look that crazy yes I can on Joe
Rogan like I'm like I'm like like the
[__] word which is a joke and you went
well you said you said you don't agree
with I don't agree with everything
that's obviously you're like well like
no obviously I don't agree with that no
obviously you don't agree with you're
trying to what this is what we going to
do what were your thought I'm going to
take this and I'mma clip this and and
try to ruin me and then I'm going to put
it out there and I'm gonna I'm going do
this whole thing in kayf I'mma do I'mma
do wrestling terms I'mma do this whole
thing I'mma clip this piece of this of
this interview I'mma put out there I'm G
put it on Twitter it's it's going you
going like it I'm going say bootleg Kev
hesitates to answer whether or not I'm
tell I'm I'm teaching everybody right
now how to cook a headline yo what's the
point and shoot here you go I'm teaching
everybody right now how to cook a
headline this is how you cook a headline
when you're writing a headline there are
three things you need number one
conflict yeah like for example uh black
iPhone on desk no
conflict right how do you inject
conflict into that headline about the
black iPhone on the desk
how device made by child slave
labor in China m left on desk now you
have something that is it'll peek you
you'll be like oh oh what is this device
that was made by child let me see what
it is let me click on this what is this
why do we need children to make this
device what's the thing what it is
that's the way you do that headline one
headline is I'm not going to I don't
care about the iPhone being on the desk
but something that kids slaves made I
care about that click on the headline
okay oh it's an iPhone [__] it's an
iPhone right selective outrage right but
now you go in there now by by the time
you get to the fact that it's a iPhone
got you [__] you you didn't clicked my
[__] aha yeah dummy it was just about an
iPhone that someone left on the desk did
you did you I mean is that let me finish
please I'm listening Cactus T now we
take we take you right and I ask you a
question you balked at it I'm not sure
why but if I cut it off right if I cut
it off if I cut it off right there I
don't have to lie it's not a
lie I can do it two ways I can either
ask a question that incites conflict
okay which is by the way is this TMZ 101
yeah okay watch bootleg and there people
much better at it than I was sure I was
a in terms of like like headline writing
yeah like much better right watch bootle
watch bootle Kev hesitate when asked if
he supports Joe Rogan's inword use now
you could do it that way I wouldn't do
that because that's leading too much
it's actually not the type of headline I
would WR I would WR I will
watch boot bootle Kev I'll probably put
it in
quotes bootleg Kev on Joel Rogan's nword
use well and I'll put that in
quotes and I will put that in quotes I
will do like whatever you said I would
like I would like I would put bootleg ke
cuz this cuz then I got this what I won
what I want in the headline number one
my name SEO I don't want your name God
bless you no who name who who name whose
name do I want Joe rogin that's the name
I want so I want Joe Rogan's name in the
headline that's fair okay so I want Joe
I might even go I might even do this I
might even put above the headline I
might put Joe Rogan right and then I
might
put
uh uh podcaster Cactus
te agrees or or
boxs uh or or hesit Ates when asked if
he likes inword usage on Joe Rogan
Experience boom we're going everywhere
now this is what I'll do then I'll take
the clip of Joe Rogan saying the n-word
over and over and over again that's a
sub asset in the post that's at the
bottom of the post oh I really yeah this
is this sound this sounds yeah oh I see
it uh this is how you do it then as a
sub asset at the bottom of the post and
then I put tags and all throughout there
I got hyperlinks I got I got Rogan's
apology in the post I got Rogan saying
the n-word in the post I Got The Whole
Nine and then I leave off on a question
I'm
wondering cuz you obviously worked at
TMZ right you're that I mean you have
one of the more famous moments ever yeah
uh was there ever anything you were a
part of over there that you ever like
regretted later on in terms of like
maybe a particular story or like what
you just told you like that um like you
just walked me through this whole thing
which was essentially your job was there
ever anything you you look back on and
you're like like damn that I was a part
of that you were a part of or there are
plenty of things that happened to TMZ
that I was embarrassed about not even
just that you were at TMZ for but like
maybe it was a story you wrote there
maybe you got wrong initially maybe you
felt you like it was an unfair approach
to that person that after you got later
context you maybe you know were like
[__] oh see here's the thing about
me there there is one
time and it's something there's
something I learn from it there was one
time where uh I did this whole thing
with a a porn star that I found out
wasn't sleeping with black Talent right
okay and so and I named the porn star M
the way I would do that now because it
was it was kind of like I'm just I'm on
TV it's early and I'm reckless I'm just
hey I found out that this porn star that
Everyone likes doesn't sleep with black
talent and who was the porn star on
camera well if I do that now it makes no
sense okay go ahead goad so if I found
out that they didn't sleep with black
talent and so I asked a question about
it and they weren't like they weren't
interp porn so the entire room they
don't really know what's going on right
so they're like oh my God like oh my God
blah blah blah Harvey goes crazy he
loves the story they put it up they put
her up there they do the whole thing now
to me is it a relevant conversation to
have about uh racism in porn or why
certain porn stars won't do scenes with
black eyes sure it's a relevant
conversation but it's such a wides
spring R widespread thing that's
probably unfair to make one person the
face of that right if you're going to
talk about it the way you talk about it
and not make one person the victim of a
lot of vitriol when that person might
not necessarily be a racist um is you
just say hey you ask the same question
cuz I asked somebody on the street I
said hey blah blah blah blah blah
doesn't do that then I name the person
you just say hey my favorite porn star
porn star I like or whatever whatever
like that and then you you have the same
conversation you get the same feel just
remove the name but somebody doesn't
have to bear the brunt of it because
it's it's an industrywide thing it's not
an industrywide thing only certain
people do it no I'm talking about just
the racism in porn in general racism in
porn is an industrywide thing and I
don't have any problem talking about
that I don't have any problem asking
somebody okay well then what's the
reason that you wouldn't work with black
Talent what is that reason because there
it's that is
it's it's such a
fundamental such a fundamentally
troubling thing to me like okay you're
you'll do all this but like not that I
mean later on I I figured out that they
I've talked to enough people black and
white and they told me that they are
just straight up business reasons for it
whatever it's their industry I'm not
going to get involved with it they can
fight their own battle but what I'm
saying is whatever it is whatever it is
forget about it whatever it is what I
have to
do is be really intentional when I want
someone to wear a problem right when I
want to put a problem on somebody when
you're on television when you're when
you have a microphone in front of you
you have to be super intentionally super
intentional when you call somebody out
because when you call somebody out you
make them the issue that you're talking
about and they have to have earned that
to such a degree you have to be so sure
about that or else you just don't care
about your own responsibility that's
something that I regretted or something
that I learned to do differently as far
as story that I might have broken to be
honest with you not really and I'll tell
you why the stories that that I was
involved with they weren't that big a
deal like I my job at TMZ I wrote a lot
of stories but my job at TMZ um
especially after the first couple of
years cuz you know I I was on the street
no well you started with like the tours
right I was on the TMZ tour and then I
was on the street right uh with the
camera sometimes those interactions
regret just like running up on somebody
like um yeah and it's because I'm from
the south and for the most part that job
was fun and for the most part for the
most part celebrities in Los Angeles
they know the deal they're cool they're
cool they're down to have a good time
but every once in a while you put the
camera on somebody and you look and
they'd have that look of I'm really
having a [__] up day like something's
going on with me like something's
happening or you put your camera on
somebody and they would be like I don't
know crying or they would be sad or you
know they're with their kids was there a
specific instance you can recall not
really not a specific one that I can
recall you know of course you would have
people get mad at you but uh not one
where I felt that I can recall that I
felt really really bad about but I just
know
that there it was like it there were
certain times to where I was like I they
not [__] feeling this today the papar
game is such an interesting one I always
have been like super intrigued by it
like I watched um did you ever see the
uh Netflix show it was only one season
where they like the ambulance Chasers
who they go and they get the footage on
like accidents and then they sell it to
like the news stations and stuff
stringers yeah yeah crazy show I forget
what it was called so good it was
actually like a Netflix original but
like on the paparazzi side it's like
someone's going to do that job right
those people like have to I mean if
that's their profession like I'm sure
Paparazzi have kids have families they
got to support themselves was it like
are there like people who have just been
doing this job cuz it feels like a means
to doing something else if if you're
doing that job no no no or there are
people who like they're 30 years yeah
been doing it for a long time been doing
it as long as they can do it for right U
because there's always somebody new and
uh because I think of like the guys who
get like the real private photos and I'm
like damn so let me tell you something
about that or
anything this they're very few jobs any
type of job that you can do that are
completely devoid of
Integrity like drug dealing is bad we
act like it's not but it is oh it's
terrible drug dealing is bad right yeah
there are levels to drug dealers there's
a way to do drug dealing to deal drugs
and we're talking about serious drugs
here talking about serious drugs yeah
like if you're [__] there are a way to
deal drugs to
do less harm than somebody else like hey
I won't de drugs to ay- old kid I won
deal drugs to a pregnant lady I w't deal
drug like there are ways to do that now
it's all bad right but there are ways to
even do that with Integrity right so if
you look at being a Paparazzi as an
inherently bad thing which once again
it's part of a celebrity ecosystem it's
really not any different than anything
else like you're famous part of being
famous is leveraging Fame and people
take your picture it's part of a
celebrity ecosystem it in of itself is
is not bad however the nature of the job
sometimes can lend itself to being
hyperco competitive and when it's
hyperco competitive then that means that
the humanity of the subjects on the
other side of the
camera are not being taken into
consideration right so if it's and the
same thing about anything else um it's I
got to be first I got to get the picture
exp photo I got to get the racest photo
so I'll stick my camera up your dress so
I'll doorstep you which means I'll be
outside of your house waiting for you to
come outside your house don't know
what's going to come outside your house
doorstepping people which TMZ didn't do
I'll uh incite you I'll put the camera
in your face and ask you about your
friend who died to try to get you to cry
or try to make you mad because that
picture is going to go everywhere
because once it gets hyper hyper
competitive and the capitalism gets
involved then that makes you look at the
person as you're a big game hunter now
you're not a photographer anymore now
you're trying to get someone you're
trying to get something to sell to a
site right right so there's to if you're
a freelancer if you're TMZ you work for
TMZ right you got to abide by their
rules right and like the way it's
supposed to be at TMZ is like you you
pick your camera up someone says hey I'm
not into it you shut your camera down
right to be respectful right it's more
of an on the street interview than it is
actually just snapping pictures that is
not to separate what TMZ Paparazzi are
doing from anybody else I I I was on the
street with a lot of different guys and
most of them are cool like most of them
are cool but then you have some guys
that don't give a [__] that are going to
get the shot however they're going to
get the shot and if they have to follow
you for a little while if they have to
wait outside your kids school if they
have to do all of that stuff they're
going to get it and so what I'm saying
is that's not indicative of the industry
per se right to me it's indicative of
what that person is willing to do to get
an extra Buck or to
succeed that's yeah I think it's just
it's like you know I I I feel like
living here you kind of see it a little
differently because like you said like
you'll talk to people and they'll
they'll like management will call and be
like yo my my my client's leaving uh
this restaurant at this time yeah I mean
that's a lot of it like not a lot of it
is that though like a lot like for
people who don't know like like like or
the artists who even do it right oh my
God bro or the artist or the actor
whatever because they want to paint
their narrative yeah I give you example
well I don't want to say name but there
was a R&B singer who was a pretty big
R&B singer at one time that I knew
through a friend of mine and you know
was at the sadd ranch in this big fancy
car and we had we were the three of us
were eating at the Saddle Ranch right we
were hanging out eating at the Saddle
Ranch and I was like when you leave here
I you privacy you on the low or whatever
and he go he goes no no it's not at all
I'm like okay well I'm going to send the
camera to you I was like no as a matter
of fact I'm not going to send the camera
to you I got my camera in the car I'm
just going to shoot you and we going to
do a little thing for TMZ and so car
pulls out it's like a big red bentle or
something like that right um
recognizable guy had hits um and I
pulled the camera out when I pulled the
camera out and I start shooting him
inside of this car everybody starts
coming around everybody's like oh my God
who is that and they know his face right
like they probably wouldn't have
bothered him any other time but they
know his face so every body's going to
man I get in my [__] and I'm going back
to the office and I get a call bro that
[__] [__] was crazy man we ought to
do that all the time bro I needed that
bro like I [__] needed that man we
should do that all the time and now you
have somebody that wants to get shots
you have people that want that you that
uh that want you to shoot them that's a
contact that's someone that if they are
ever involved in a story you could hit
them now that you have that relationship
or someone tangental to them is ever
involved into a story with with a story
now you have that relationship so there
is not for the most part at least while
I was there there an adversarial
relationship between TMZ and the
celebrity at large most of the
celebrities dig it I don't know how it
is now things have changed a little bit
but but most celebrities dug it to me
most and if they didn't dig it they
didn't have a problem with it they got
it right then there are some who just
can't [__] stand it like Iggy is yeah
Iggy Mel Gibson the [__]
uh the
uh um like Owen and Luke Wilson oh they
don't [__] with it don't [__] with it
like a lot of people like that don't
[__] with it and if I ever saw if I saw
a black celebrity and they were in a
situation to where like remember one
time I saw
uh I saw Golden
Brooks nice sweet lady she was eating
she was at um she was actually with
Regina King oh [__] they were they were
eating this is years ago Watchman season
2 please [__] no not Regina King she was
with Regina Hall um she was with she was
with Regina Hall and they were eating at
uh on Sunset and I remember I was
walking around with my camera and I
asked them two black women I'm not
trying to I asked they trying to roll
yeah yeah they were eating I'm asking
them like after you guys done do you
want to do a shop and they went no move
on yeah not a big deal somebody else
will be around you know but it's just
all of that stuff once again it's part
of an ecosystem what I will say say
about TMZ is this there is a lot of
criticism that TMZ gets right yeah from
all all kinds of people you get
criticism for T from from TMZ people
tell you you worked there you did this
you did that all that stuff people hate
TMZ they hate it everybody is TMZ true
like everyone is TMZ because guess what
when you see that famous person what do
you
do I mean that in two ways number one
when people know that you work there it
doesn't matter where you go you go sit
down at the nicest restaurant in La I'm
in La I mean at I'm at cut I sit down
somebody comes over they know me from
the show hey just let you know Tom Hanks
is going to be here in a little bit you
know what I'm saying oh [__] the valet
everyone everyone wants to be a part of
it that's one thing do you tip them yeah
if they give you a good they give you a
good tip yeah I would
um and the other part of it is
this if you are an
Outlet or you are a radio
station you are
blog you're
whatever and you repurpose a TMZ
story meaning you report on what they
reported right you give the information
that they got your TMZ yeah I mean I've
used TMZ so much like like what they
want more than anything is for other
people to pick up the things I think
like and so and so my thing is I've had
there have been so many places where
even when I was working there and even
after that I've been criticized right
and then I hear them say according to
TMZ this and this and happen if that's
like you can't have that both ways if a
place is too [__] up for you either
you're going to say this place has to
exist and you want them to be better or
you're not going to [__] with them and
then on top of that most of these other
celebrities I've had celebrities or
people that I know directly criticize
TMZ and what they've done
and then I'll see them when they have
something to promote on TMZ live you
can't do it that way yeah yeah it's like
you're going to [__] on TMZ but then
when you when you which by the way when
I was there there were
times where the website wasn't a little
irresponsible it was insanely
irresponsible downright racist sexist
insensitive the whole nine when I was
there um uh there was an attack a an
attachment uh post 2016 to Donald Trump
that TMZ did a lot of his bidding I'm
not at all caping for the organization
but what I'm saying is with some place
like that that thrives on attention the
sharing of stories it's kind of like the
Vlad thing right it's like people talk
[__] about Vlad but then they'll go on
his show and they have to promote their
album or they need some clout or they're
washed the reality is it's a massive
platform yeah it's a huge platform and
so and so people and I don't want to
compare Vlad and TMZ because that I
don't want to do that cuz you know look
I I there's nothing inherently wrong
with TMZ there's inherently wrong with
what vad is doing vad is doing
interviews TMZ is doing celebrity news
the the the reality is if you have a
problem with it if you have a problem
with it the only way to do the only way
to really affect that problem is to not
participate consume that's the only
thing you can do and the reality is is
that the influence on
the the website um and the platform on
culture is too strong for anyone to
really do that the way I look at uh most
people some people like TMZ is like
they've
been
right like almost like I feel like they
you know when they're not right they
update the story in such a real time
that it's like very few times you
they're going to be inaccurate yeah and
it's I mean as a radio personality
always like yo let's check TMZ what's
I'll give you an example people said
that TMZ was inaccurate on the Little
Wayne story remember that M do you
remember the story was it when he was it
when he got arrested all right so I'm
I'm going to do another
TMZ uh no it wasn't when he was arrested
when he was uh sick oh yes okay yes when
he was having his seizures yeah little L
way I remember
that this was one of the times I caught
some of the most hell okay um all right
so March 2013 TMZ reported that Lil
Wayne was in a coma and received his
last rights at C SI Hospital I remember
this yeah in Los Angeles okay uh so
let's look at I'mma give I'mma give
everyone right now another little lesson
because here's the story right now um
let's look at it so it's been updated a
bunch of times right now but you
originally wrote this story no I didn't
have anything to do with it I was uh I
was um I was on the street at this time
okay so it says this it says Lil Wayne
is in ICU critical condition after
suffering yet another seizure we're told
it doesn't look good TMZ has learned we
brought the story The 30-year-old rapper
was red see sign in that hospital we
first of all prayers up for Wayne glad
that Wayne is happy healthy and doing
well just using this as example is one
of the things so all of this stuff that
is is being a legend
here is being confirmed through sources
so someone is telling someone this right
okay someone is telling someone that
this is what is going on okay so let me
tell you what a lie is journalistically
here is that that person isn't telling
us that if we're making that up right
now so when they say little Wayne is in
critical condition and he's being read
his last right Source had said that no
no no if a source says that and then it
is put up on TMZ and it's attributed to
sources then that story is legit right
if the source said it if the source said
that then the the story is legit now if
Lou Wayne pulls through the sour said
hey it doesn't look good that's that
person's objective interpretation of
what's going on doesn't look good
somebody came in like they're preparing
for something objective opinion now Lil
Wayne rebounded and the whole world went
the whole world went TMZ lied it was
never that big of a deal give people an
example of something you're married I'm
not calling this on your marriage I'm
just using this as an example
if you got brothers or sisters one
sister got one sister if I walk into a
restaurant right now and someone says if
I'm on the basketball court and someone
that I've never met before says hey you
know Bole I saw you on this podcast and
I'm like yeah it's like buev is getting
a divorce not not buev is not getting a
divorce God protect his marriage um says
bule Kev is getting a divorce if I run
to the website and put that up on the
website that's an irresponsible story
cuz who's your Source who's my source
you have a sister my sister tells you if
your sister tells
me right if your sister tells me then
then it's like well that's that's a
that's a sour sources close to ble Kev
say the marriage is on the rocks and
divorce is on the table or something
yeah if you do not get divorced that
does not make that story less true the
story is not you getting divorced or not
getting divorced the story is your
sister who they don't know who she is
I'm not you're not going to out your
Source right told us that you were
getting a divorce the strength of that
and that goes for journalism everywhere
hey before the Dos decision is coming
out uh somebody gets a hold of the
opinion that somebody wrote or someone
like this hasn't leaked yet but
according to sources that tell ABC News
news this information is coming out well
if the information doesn't come out ABC
News would be embarrassed of course and
so you have to do your due diligence
with the sources that you have that
they're not going to double back on you
right but the reality of the situation
is if you have a source and that source
is Ironclad and that source is in with
whomever you're talking about that's a
goal on that story the question about
whether or not you would report
something that's that serious unless you
knew it to be to be to be 1,00% true
that's different varies varies platform
to platform platform to platform when
you report about Michael Jackson and the
fact that he had passed away you haven't
seen the body you haven't checked his
pulse right you haven't done any of that
stuff you don't know when you report on
Prince like you you haven't seen his
dead body right somebody that knows him
really well said he was dead yeah and so
and you know that to be true you're
staking your relationship with them in a
in a journalistic way of them on them
being a good source right so when I say
that they're normally
right it's if if they if something
is factually correct or factually
incorrect it normally won't go up on the
site I'll talk about one story that I
did have Jason Pier Paul the football
player remember him jpp fireworks
incident maybe yep I knew about that
hours before it happened hours like
hours before it happened somebody me and
literally went hey man jpp just blew his
hand off with some
fireworks hours before it happened it
ended up cuz that was on Fourth of July
right and so it ended up happening maybe
at a certain time it was on the east
coast and I couldn't ever put it up on
the site I couldn't put up on the site
because I couldn't confirm it I couldn't
get a picture of it right I couldn't get
any of that stuff right I could have
gone on the source that he did that but
it's such a finite thing that when it's
this has happened not this will happen
but this has happened I even need to be
able to talk to somebody that saw the
hand and can give me pictures of the
hand I need to be Ironclad cuz I can't
put that up
and cuz that's a straight either
happened or it didn't happen either
happened or it didn't happen that's a
straight up lie so guess what that's
fair we put it on the story we couldn't
get it right the guy who did get it I
think it was shefer probably yeah he
violated HIPPA laws to get it because he
got the [__] I remember him getting in
trouble I don't want to say shefer if it
wasn't shefer so cuz I don't want to get
yeah you don't want to like yeah but
somebody somebody you take out the thing
okay there was there was actually
somebody who did get it that violated
HIPPA laws to get the story and ended up
getting in trouble we weren't going to
do that we weren't going to call we
weren't going to call any hospitals to
try to get it we were call any doctors
to try to get it I was trying to get
deeper into his inner circle to have
someone give me a picture of damn that's
crazy I feel like that world the shefer
like uh you know the Shams versus W
world that shit's crazy M it's so it's
it's it's it's like the sports TMZ it's
the same thing I mean we have TMZ sports
so it's the same thing but we didn't do
contract stuff it was more lifestyle
stuff around the guys but it's the same
thing a a trade is about to happen like
uh at three hours from now yeah they
send it to W send it to W they send it
to w w bomb boom what if they didn't
take the deal off the table did w lie no
somebody told him that
you know what I'm saying for sure